the right man in the wrong place can
make all the difference in the world so
wake up mr. Freeman wake up and smell
the ashes it's hard to predict the
impact a game might have long after its
release these things need time to
percolate to sink in to become part of
the mediums culture we need to be able
to look back and see them in the grand
scheme of things but in the case of
half-life 2 in 2004 it seemed obvious
right away this game would change things
and it did even if you still haven't
played it you've seen its influence
everywhere half-life 2 set precedents
for the way games can tell stories both
in the first-person shooter genre and
elsewhere it showed how physics pacing
and a cohesive world can all combine to
form a narrative epic many games would
not exist today at Valve's sequel hadn't
first blazed the trail Bioshock Dead
Space
The Last of Us and Wolfenstein the new
order just to name a few but we also
wouldn't have the metro series from for
a games and in the wake of Microsoft's
e3 2017 press conference where we got
our first glimpse at Metro Exodus the
third game in that series I want to turn
your attention to that game's
predecessor Metro last light the 2013
title is a fluid blend of horror and
survival set within the decrepit tunnels
of post-apocalyptic Russia it's also
criminally underappreciated and one of
the most brilliant shooters ever made
but in a wider sense it did something
even more important it came along at a
time when story driven first-person
shooters were few and far between it
also borrowed from the best shooter ever
made continuing half-life 2's legacy and
setting new precedents of its own the
Metro is a living breathing thing
with a heartbeat a soul
[Music]
to understand the significance of both
titles its first important to understand
the climate in which they released in
2004 half-life 2 launched within weeks
of halo 2 grand theft auto san andreas
world of warcraft and the original Star
Wars Battlefront that holiday season was
packed with household franchise names at
a time when the medium was showing a
major focus on multiplayer titles
despite the anticipation spawned from
the original half-life its sequel
released at a more than difficult time
nine years later last light did the same
thing 2013 saw the release of another
new Grand Theft Auto a battlefield and
Assassin's Creed and of course a Call of
Duty games whose names alone guaranteed
sales despite their sometimes evident
fatigue this was also the year of
BioShock Infinite and the Last of Us two
games that told sweeping stories in a
dystopian society and post-apocalyptic
America the Last of Us did feature a
multiplayer component but in general
these releases were largely geared
toward those who craved a single-player
narrative with the pedigree of
Irrational Games and Naughty Dog however
they had no problem finding an audience
last light on the other hand didn't have
the same advantages it was a sequel to
Metro 2033 a cult classic based on the
series of novels by Russian writer
Dmitry Glukhovsky its developer for a
games was largely unknown as well
what's more the bankruptcy of publisher
THQ forced the developer to find a new
home midway through last light's
development yet somehow this didn't
deter 4a games from making a wholly
original atmospheric shooter like
half-life 2 it tells its story in novel
confident ways in a setting that seeps
into every mechanic and system at play
valve sequel was famous for its lack of
cutscenes instead opting to keep the
player rooted in protagonist gordon
freeman with total first-person control
over his movement and eyeline NPCs
delivered their dialogue as you move
throughout the environment creating a
sense of presence that a cutscene
couldn't all in all there's an
astonishing lack of exposition in
half-life 2 it tells its tale through
environmental cues character quirks and
the numerous ways you can manipulate the
world Last Light does this as well its
environments foreshadow the threats
you'll soon be facing its characters
accompany you at different times
throughout the story changing the
context of your actions and your
motivations for doing so
last life does have cutscenes but most
of them are brief or used to illustrate
a point
for instance the camera shifts to third
person when protagonist Artyom saves the
last dark one it's a method to emphasize
a similarity between their species
outside of these rare shifts though last
light makes a clear effort to keep you
rooted in Artyom shoes which is all to
say that neither half-life 2 nor last
light erode their narratives with
heavy-handed explanations they drop you
in forcing you to make sense of the
world as you go the settlements in
half-life's European dystopia feel
established as do the Stations of metros
Russian underground neither valve nor 4a
explicitly tell us that the characters
are accustomed to these ways of life
they show us perhaps most importantly
these are shooters in which the shooting
itself is not actually the main focus
it's the world building that's key the
shooting just helped to reinforce it the
most notable example is half-life 2's
iconic gravity gun not only does it let
you manipulate your surroundings and the
game's lauded physics engine but it also
makes sense both for your character and
within the game's world it's the kind of
makeshift weapon a scientific everyman
might theoretically use if he were
rising up against an oppressive military
regime less lights items guns and tools
take this contextual realism to its
extreme you manually pump pneumatic
weapons constructed from the scavenge
remains of the russian wasteland enemy
outfits are Frankenstein's monsters of
sheet metal dirty rags and hazmat suits
couple all of this with last night's
survival systems and the
post-apocalyptic atmosphere becomes even
more palpable assuming you're playing
less light on Ranger difficulty which in
my opinion is the only way to play this
game you'll have a limited HUD and
scarce or supplies you've glanced at
your guns magazine to see how many
rounds you have left you check your
watch to see the time remaining before
your suffocation when your gas mask
begins to spiderweb across your screen
you have to search high and low for a
replacement and of course your
high-grade ammunition doubles as
currency in a world where paper money
and coins are all but gone you're forced
to spend actual bullets at markets and
kiosks similar to bottle caps in the
Fallout games met Rosie
economy is shaped by what the people
deem valuable in this world in this case
bullets to defend themselves with
many of these things aren't necessarily
fun in the traditional sense in any
other game pumping your weapon charging
your flashlights battery or swapping
currency into and out of your magazine
could feel tedious but in last light
they contribute to the makeshift whims
of the metros inhabitants they make you
feel not like a soldier but like a
survivor like half-life 2's gravity gun
they ground you in this different world
the influences are here on a wire scale
as well much can be said about half-life
2's pacing and the way it propels you
from set pieces to set piece crafting
sandboxes and linear segments of light
it expertly handles the highs and lows
of a lengthy shooter campaign and last
slight follow suit in fact if you pay
close attention you'll notice how
similar the structures of the two games
really are you begin at a dystopian
settlement you're called away on a
mission a vehicle section emphasizes the
scope of your quest you venture into a
sinister area with otherworldly
creatures you actually cross a dangerous
bridge signaling your point of no return
you ally with those that were previously
your enemies you reach the end of your
journey where everything culminates in a
heated battle which is all to say that
last light touches on similar story
beats that half life 2 did emphasizing
the hero's journey that takes place from
beginning to end it understands what
made its forebear seminal to begin with
and warps it to fit a new world in a new
era for the medium we have rates and
d'afrique all caught in the same net I
do not like it so talk or take a bullet
to the brain
[Music]
[Music]
now Metro last light is not perfect it's
a I could have used some work and I
still can't stand the journal entries
spoken by the otherwise silent Artyom in
between chapters but last light realizes
how powerful the first-person shooter
genre can really be it builds a world
and crafts an atmosphere that leaves a
lasting impression everything else is in
service to that world building Metro
2033 may have been a cult classic and
last light may still be underappreciated
but with Metro Exodus on the horizon I
think it's time that more people
experienced forays phenomenal shooters
we probably won't see half-life's next
episode anytime soon but with games like
Last Light continuing the legacy of
Valve's legendary sequel it's hard to
care too much I can rest assured that
narrative driven first-person shooters
will always find an audience and they'll
always attract the creative minds to
make them so here's hoping that Metro
Exodus continues that tradition
[Music]